Doo doo,
Doo,
Doo Doo,
Doo Doo.
You know,
just being on tinder the whole time.
We're live.
You can't talk about tinder dudes.
She can shot it off.
Don't swipe right.
Steve Hofstetter.
Ladies and gentlemen already ready.
That was at the same time.
I'm good.
I'm excited to be here.
I'm excited to have you,
man.
I'd love the video.
There's a video I found out about Steve
because it's a video of some fucking
hecklers.
Why do they still exist?
The people out there.
Do you not know that when you come to a
comedy show,
it's like going to the movies.
You shouldn't try to contact ego and
alcohol.
You're right.
That's the answer.
I asked.
Asked a rhetorical question
and I got a definitive answer.
It's a fucking great video though
because you handled it so well.
I don't remember the subject.
What was.
What was she a heckling about?
It was about.
I was talking about how parents think
they're special and they're not.
That's right,
and then she yelled out bullshit and
then walked into two minutes of material
that I already had written about the
subject.
If I had written what she was supposed
to say,
it wouldn't have been as good as what
she actually said.
Yeah.
It was like a setup and sometimes those
things happen and people accused people
doing plants.
I've never heard of anybody actually
doing a plant though.
You other than Andy Kaufman.
No,
like not even.
Not one time,
but people.
Some Times people look at the world and
they go,
well,
this is too good.
It can't be real.
Sleep will allow for some magic that
happens sometimes.
A little comedy magic.
Yeah.
I mean there's so many videos of
hecklers.
You would think that they would learn
like there's.
Is there a video of a heckler winning?
I mean,
there,
there are definitely videos of people
who are like,
I own this heckler.
And then like,
did you,
did you looks Kinda.
No,
not really sometimes,
but that's not the heckler winning.
That's the comedian losing,
right?
There's,
there's a difference.
You know,
the end there are,
um,
there are times I think when they're
comedians,
you know this,
they're comedians who can't ad Lib,
who are brilliant at material but are
just not add libbers.
If that's weird,
isn't it,
like the people that only want to do
like monologues and if anything goes
offline,
like they ignore it and they just keep
going and they hope that someone takes
care of it.
Well,
I don't,
I don't understand that like that.
That's part of people sometimes will be
like,
why do you have so many heckler videos?
It's like,
because most of them start with me
going,
what'd you say?
Yeah.
Because I don't,
I don't let it go because I don't want
to lose control of the crowd.
I don't want other people to be like,
oh well he talked,
I can talk.
And also I,
you know,
I just,
I can't concentrate on this bit.
I've done a thousand times.
If in the back of my head I was like,
wait,
what's happening right now in the back
of the room?
Yeah.
Well sometimes people just start
commenting like they'll like be right in
front of you too.
Just crazy.
Like in the front row go,
no,
that's not true.
No,
you can't say that.
Don't say that.
Or they even go.
Yes,
that's true.
Like when they agree with you,
it still sucks,
but what about.
Yeah.
Then they want to put their own spin on
it.
Like it's a conversation.
He had a seizing sometimes,
like I try to tell people,
I'm like,
look,
comedies evocative.
You're going to have a lot of thoughts
and that's okay.
Have the thoughts hold onto those
thoughts later after the show released
thoughts in the wild.
But for now it's okay to think of stuff
and even if you see me out in the lobby
and you want to have you got a question
about some of the material.
Let's talk.
Yeah,
that's a time to talk.
Absolutely not.
Not why you're halfway into the setup.
Yeah,
it is.
It's such.
I mean,
part of why I say it's ego is because if
there's hundreds of people at this show
and they're all quiet and then one
person thinks they're all doing it
wrong.
Yeah.
Like they're just sitting there and be
like,
wait,
no,
all these people are wrong there.
We should be interacting.
I need to show them.
It is kind of funny that alcohol's would
they serve at comedy clubs because for I
guess for most people it's a good thing.
For most people.
Alcohol is a social lubricant relaxes
you.
You start laughing a little bit more,
but for some people the fucking,
the wheels come off and they just want
to chime in and yell out,
well,
if you're an asshole,
alcohol just makes you more of an
asshole.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So I think I've had this theory for a
long time that a lot of people will
blame being drunk.
Oh,
I was so wasted.
It's like,
but that's you.
You were still in there.
There isn't some magical like jekyll and
Hyde thing that's going on.
You peed on someone's truck because he
wanted a p on someone's truck.
Alcohol just gave you the excuse.
There are people that are alcoholics
though.
We're a switch goes off.
Do you know anybody like that?
Um,
I,
I don't.
You know what,
but I can introduce you to a fair.
I was like,
I have a feeling.
I know who some of the people you hang
with A.
I guess I don't hang out at the store
and the store is the grand old opry for
hecklers.
Yeah,
I mean it really is this.
There's something about that place
because there's no real dorman.
Everybody's a comic.
It's comics working the gate or comics
working the door.
Comics work in the cover booth.
Comics working the room.
It's the only comics.
Comics work in the back parking lot.
It's all Comedians,
so when you're there,
you're.
You're under the hands of people who
really don't want to be doing what
they're doing.
They don't really pay attention,
so you have to learn how to deal with
hecklers.
Plus it's a hangout so that places.
There's people packed in that place from
8:00 PM til 2:00 AM and everybody's
hanging around drinking and so there's a
lot of alcoholics and so you just get
used to those dudes that have shark
eyes.
Their eyes glass over and they're gone.
You look in there,
you're like,
oh,
bobby's not here anymore.
I didn't meet people like that until I
was 30.
When I.
When I was 30 I started to meet like
real alcoholics where they'd have one
drink and then they were gone.
They're just off to the races.
But do you think so do you think that
they are a completely different person
or do you think that the alcohol just
allows who they are to come out?
Completely speculative because I don't
have that gene.
Whatever that wacky gene is where you
have a couple of drinks and you just go
off the rails.
I don't have that.
I'm a happy drunk.
Like when I get drunk I like to laugh
and hug people.
I don't.
I don't understand the goal blank.
Make a multicav cocktail throat at the
cops wake up in jail.
What the fuck?
What happened?
Who did what?
The weirdest drunk to me is the is the
crying drunk drunk.
That gets super upset because then it's
like,
why would you,
why would you give yourself the
ingredient that you need to cry in the
corner?
Like if you know,
if it's the first time it ever happened,
I get it.
Okay.
But if you're someone like,
I have a friend who every time he gets
drunk he gets like super sad and I was
like,
stop drinking.
It's like,
why are you drinking if you're this
upset?
I feel like with people like that,
there's patterns that are deeply carved
into their psyche from childhood.
Like maybe their mom cried.
A lot of their dad cried a lot and they
got used to it and became a comforting
pattern.
But yeah,
those things are.
I mean people say,
Oh,
well what are you gonna do man?
And the guy said,
well,
how the fuck did he get sad lives in
America?
He's got two feet,
doesn't have cancer.
The fuck is he whining about there can
be 100 things wrong.
You're a young white person in America.
We shut up.
I actually don't drink anymore.
I've been sober 12 years.
Damn.
And it was because it was really my
first year on the road when I realized
like,
how much of a problem it could be.
Oh,
so you get it wrong.
So you did it as a preventative measure.
I did it.
Yeah.
It was something where I didn't go
through a program and I found by the way
that like people who have gone through
the program or like,
you know,
really,
really sober and to me I'm just like,
you needed a program,
you have no willpower,
you know,
so it's a bit of a dichotomy there idea
that someone could tell you after 12
years of sobriety that you're not
really.
This isn't even consistent.
Yeah.
You don't,
you just choose not to drink and like,
yeah,
I do choose not to drink,
but it's,
yeah.
I haven't had a drink at 12 years.
It was a,
it was one of these things where,
I mean,
you know this,
it's free on the road,
you know,
and everybody wants.
Everybody goes,
Oh,
let me take a shot with you afterward
and be like,
there are 30 of you.
I'm going to die.
Right.
You just do the math on that and you're
like,
I'm going to die.
And I started realizing,
you know what?
I don't have inhibition that alcohol
changes.
Like that same year I had done,
I'd done some show in Bloomington,
Indiana and we went to a bar afterwards
and they were a bunch of hot girls
dancing on the bar and I went up in a
dance on the bar with them and I wasn't
drunk.
I just wanted to dance with the hot
girls and there were all these like
there all these drunk people you know,
below the bar,
like all these loser guys just kinda
like nursing their beer and looking up
and be like,
I wish I could do that and be like,
well then get the fuck up on the bar.
Why?
If you want to do it,
do it.
Can anybody just dance on the bar?
Because that makes me reconsider all the
Times I've touched the bar and then
touched food and then.
Oh yeah,
my phone up there and touch that and
then touched food in the bottom of my
shoes are not clean Joe.
Nobody's shoes are clean.
How will you just allowed to.
Is that,
that's kind of violate health codes,
right?
It was a,
I just figure there were enough hot
girls that it was okay that I was there
too.
That's a good call.
Like the ratio has to be.
There have to be still be enough hot
girls.
Now,
did you hook up with one of those girls
afterwards?
Oh No,
I was a pathetic,
sad loser,
but the point is that that I,
I didn't need the alcohol to at least
start the process of getting rejected.
That's you.
You have,
you have the unique personality trait
that allows you to get crazy dance on
bars.
Yeah.
That is a strange thing though about the
people that are in those 12 step
programs because they really do get
super attached to the idea that that's
the only way to be sober.
Yeah.
And it's not.
It is a way and if you need that.
Okay.
Yeah.
More power to you and I,
I,
you know,
I do not,
I don't want to take that away from
anybody,
but we're all different and everybody's,
you know,
nerve endings connect differently.
Whatever the hell that biology is of it.
And I didn't need to program,
especially because I would freak out if
they were like,
and this is about Jesus and it will be
like,
go fuck yourself,
give me a beer.
So I,
you know,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be able to be comfortable
there.
Did you,
did you ever do a program thing?
Did you go to an alcoholics anonymous
meeting or just stop now?
I had a.
So I had,
there were a couple of times where I was
like,
alright,
I need to,
I need to quit and quit and that never
works.
And then there was one night where,
so it's,
it's the first real time on the road.
I was terrible with women in high school
and college and then suddenly I hit the
road as a comic and they're everywhere
and they're interested and life is
different.
And so there was a show.
I was doing the show first already.
And usually the sororities that sponsor
comedy shows or like the philanthropy
sorority and they're all terrible.
Uh,
no,
these girls were all hot.
Just,
just dimes.
The whole chapter just full.
They had like one ugly friend is as the
charity,
but they just gorgeous girls and my
opener goes up and bombs and then I go
up to a standing room only crowd and
crush and so now it's afterward we're
hanging out.
There's like this after party thing that
they put together for just them and the
two of us,
one of which they hated because he
bombed and the like,
they're just these eight hot girls
surrounding me.
One shoulder,
another one out of the way to sit next
to me.
I was like,
this is,
this is like nothing I've ever
experienced.
And then they took us to another party
and I'm pretty sure some will put
something in my drink.
Not In the way of like I want to fuck
this guy in the way of like,
this is a guy getting all the attention
away from the other guys.
And I think one of the other guys fucked
with my drink.
Real.
Yeah.
Because I got super violently ill very
quickly,
like very,
very quickly.
And I spent the whole night I was
supposed to stay at the sorority house.
Like the plan was.
I was going to stay in the guest room so
I didn't even have to do the whole
excuse of like,
Hey,
can I use your bathroom?
Can I come in for like,
I just,
I was supposed to go back there with
them and I spent the entire night just,
just vomiting.
It was terrible.
Spiked your drink and then I lost a Gig
the next day and at the time.
So my first year on the road I lost a
$1,500 gig the next day.
Because you were so sick.
I couldn't do it.
I was,
we were driving,
it was the middle of winter,
but I was wearing two pairs of pants,
like two sweatshirts and in a sleeping
bag in the car with the heat on full and
I was shivering the whole way.
Like I was fucked up so don't sure you
didn't have the flu or something.
That sounds like the flu.
It went away like six hours later.
So it could've been,
it could've been a very temporary.
Flew a well timed.
Flew.
I don't know,
but that was the night where I was just
like,
I can't keep up
doing this.
Have you ever heard of a drug that does
that?
Like a drug that makes you have the
chills?
Man.
Me,
they're probably not.
I might just be like,
no,
it doesn't sound like it.
That sounds like you got something
happened.
Yeah,
it was,
uh,
I,
it was just very,
very bad.
And so I realized that it was,
it was not only a chance at like a
three,
it was a chance that like a nine some.
So you're like,
all right.
That was more drinking.
Yeah,
none of that.
Wow.
That's a,
that's a wake up call.
Yeah.
The world hands you four aces and you
just throw up on them.
What a hand of cards
that you ever heard of the term dry
drunk.
Now what's that?
Dry drunk is what people like to say.
People who are alcoholics who aren't
drinking but aren't in the program,
are there dry drunks?
And so you still have all the mental
issues that are drunk has.
You're just waiting to go off.
You don't really have the stability that
a 12 step program provides.
That sounds.
That sounds right.
Yeah.
I mean for some people for sure,
but a 12 step program is weird because
it doesn't require belief in a higher
power.
It does.
They.
There's a lot of God stuff in there and
like I believe that there was something,
but that something could be a life
force.
It could be an energy.
I don't know what,
but I believe it's very possible.
There's something.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't believe that there's A.
I don't believe that there's a bearded
man and wings and all that bullshit.
Be Dope.
There was though.
It wasn't that if you got up to heaven,
he realized that it was all true and
you'll be amazing.
That's so crazy.
I was just a marketing thing.
I just listened to a radio lab the other
day about addiction and they said that
95 or sorry I'm gonna start that over of
100 people.
If they started at a aaa on January
first as of December 30,
first of that year,
only five would still be in the program.
Basically saying like,
it doesn't work,
but there's a lot of factors that could
be at that could mean that or why that
could happen because some people could
start a different program,
they can go to the meeting next door,
but they're saying like only five
percent of people will stay in the
program three years through some certain
statistics.
That's a shit retention,
right?
Yeah,
but that was a that that radiolab goes
into this,
a pill that can cure addiction.
I think.
Well,
they've had an Ibogaine forever.
I began as,
I don't know,
it's a drug that it's from the Boga
plant and it's supposed to be fantastic
for people that have heroin addiction,
alcohol addiction,
even addictive personality disorders
problems,
things
along those lines.
It's supposedly this ruthlessly
introspective psychedelic experience
that brutally breaks down your pathways.
You're thinking pathways and shows you
why you keep going into this self
sabotage mode and it's apparently
unbelievably uncomfortable to go
through.
Psychologically,
physically it's not.
It doesn't feel good,
but when it's over,
the rate of retention of the retention
of sobriety,
that rate of sobriety that people retain
afterwards is staggering.
It's like in the eighties,
the high,
80 percent better than anything.
Ruthlessly introspective.
It sounds like a great name of a comedy
album does,
right?
Yeah.
The,
there's a,
there's a treatment center on the one on
one,
like that [inaudible] I passed by and it
like,
it looked like a college campus almost
and I was like,
what the hell is that?
And I looked it up and there's like a,
it's like a treatment center,
like an inpatient and you like cut out
everyone in your life kind of thing.
It's one of those,
it's one of those like,
yeah,
you know,
you're not allowed to talk to people for
six months.
But when I looked it up,
I found that on Google and there were
reviews and one of the reviews was if
someone who is about to go into the
treatment center and he gave it one
star,
like he was reviewing his own life,
like he was that mess.
He like reviewed.
He's like,
well I'm about to take the journey.
The first step of the journey of
sobriety.
And it was one star and I was like,
I think you may have misunderstood how
this rating system works,
buddy.
It might be a dick.
Yeah.
Give something one star if you haven't
even tried it.
I love when you ever just read yelp
reviews too.
Unfortunately.
I love mad at myself.
I know.
But I love when you learn more about the
person and the restaurant.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
There was one I saw in New York where,
uh,
this girl,
like she opens the review like,
so I,
I'm back dating again and I'm like,
that's not telling me how the pasta is.
Yeah.
Like I don't,
I don't need to know that.
But she uses it or has her own blog.
It was fascinating though because then
you get to know,
should I listen to this moron?
Let me,
let me see what they have to say about
David.
Why is it that men these days don't want
to open up a car door,
don't want open up a door for a lady.
Get upset when you're expected to pay
and don't understand that you do want
your own career.
And like,
and as it turns out that Niki was
fantastic.
Yeah.
You're just annoying.
There's a lot of those.
I always go to someone's bad review.
I always go to their page and see what
they think about other stuff.
Yeah.
Just so you can figure out.
It's also tough,
like using yelp sometimes in the middle
of nowhere.
That's really tough because then you're
like,
these motherfuckers don't know Sushi.
Like what do they,
what do they know?
Sushi in South Dakota.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fishman.
Yeah.
Yelp is tricky because it's like youtube
reviews and lots of other things.
You're relying on random people you
don't like.
Like if I call you up and I go,
Hey Steve,
what do you think about this?
Well,
I know Steve's an intelligent guy.
He's going to give me a really nuanced
thought out opinion of whatever we're
discussing.
But if you don't know a person,
you just reading their type,
their type could be.
I mean,
when they write,
write things down there,
the printed word could be just as valid
as some fucking psychopaths printed word
mean you don't.
You really don't know.
You don't.
You got to go deep,
deep,
deep into their,
their paragraphs and you get to really
try to decipher like,
how fucking nuts is this person?
I have a theory.
I have a theory that the way we make
online tolerable that way we make like,
you know,
online not be this,
just I guess Bastian for angry thought
is everyone's not name,
but everyone's job shouldn't be in
parenthesis,
so we know what people do for a living.
That would help in like how many stars
your coworkers give.
You usually get your,
you get yelled at before you're allowed
to yelp.
You know that guy with one star.
I bet he gives out a half a star.
I bet it all the people who work with
him,
they give him a half a star and he puts
one star in for the,
the drug review place and get one star
for his mom.
For Dope Mom.
There was an app that came out that was
like a yelp for people and everyone got
really upset.
What was he yelled for?
Dating.
It was.
Oh,
so it wasn't just okay because it was
people you've dated because I thought I
thought the idea because it was,
you know,
the reviews of people and people getting
upset and I was like,
the only people who would get upset at
that are the people who know they're
going to get two stars.
Well,
it's people can just stock,
you know,
someone who's like a Shitty coworker who
had,
that's true,
has it against you can write a bunch of
mean shit about you and then every time
you pull up your name,
you see this means shit written against
you.
Yet you need to,
I think for the way that to work for the
way for that to work as you can only
review someone if you both agree to
review each other.
I was reading this thing about this guy
who's getting stalked online,
but this other guy and uh,
they found the person and it was a 17
year old kid that was the son of one of
his friends and had no real beef with
them.
But it was just doing it for sport just
for the fun of it.
Because he knew he could fuck with the
guy and scare him and he did all this
Holocaust Jews stuff and all this
antisemitic stuff is really,
really crazy stuff like sent ashes to
their house and left ashes at their
front door.
Like a,
just a total psychopath,
a kid,
17 year old kid and it apparently had
haunted this guy for a long time and he
was trying to figure out who it was.
Then he hired someone that's pretty easy
to find people.
Once you hire someone who's an expert,
they found the kid like instantly and
they realized it was this fucking high
school kid that was the son of one of
his friends and they all had a sit down
and he.
They printed up all the stuff that this
kid had written for like a fucking year
and handed it to him and the kid started
crying and I don't know why I did it.
And I got addicted to it.
I couldn't stop and like addicted to it.
Well now you're playing a game.
Know,
and if you're not there when the person
is reacting,
especially when you're and your
emotions,
maybe they're not so complex or they're
not so rather formed and not,
they're not mature.
Maybe completely aware that every action
has a reaction on the other end whether
you see it or not,
there is a,
uh,
you know,
that movie though the button or whatever
it was where like someone like press a
button and someone would die in the
world.
I heard about that.
I never saw it.
I didn't either,
but there was,
I think it was an snl sketch about it
where they were like,
they explain the whole premise or like
you press this button in somewhere,
someone the world die and the guy just
hits the button and they're like,
we didn't let us finish.
Like we would give you a million dollars
and he just hits it again because we're,
we're that like inhuman,
impersonal.
Like if you just tell me that someone
somewhere else in the world died,
like that doesn't really affect you.
Yeah.
There's too many people anyway.
Hit the button.
Let's clear up the four.
Oh,
five.
Yeah,
I guess it just depends on who.
so if you don't feel it,
it feels like
problem with drones,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they say that drone pilots,
what is this?
Oh,
is that the,
the.
They say that a drone pilots suffer
through a lot of severe anxiety when
they're done and like it,
it's apparently incredibly
psychologically stressful because you're
doing this weird thing where you sort of
sending this robot and they're doing it
from Nevada.
Right?
So the robots are in Afghanistan or
Pakistan or Yemen or wherever the hell
they are and they're launching missiles
from the sky robots and it just feels so
detached and creepy to the people that
are doing it.
Well,
it's the same,
I guess the same psychology of like why
you're able to get into such credit card
debt,
but you wouldn't do that with cash
because like you were,
you,
you see it as just some mythical thing
and then afterward you realize,
oh,
this is real life.
You would you be able to,
would you be able to kill someone if you
knew that they were like a bad guy?
Yeah.
And would you feel bad about it?
No,
that's what I think too.
Yeah.
I don't think I would.
I mean if someone like Hitler character.
Yeah.
I don't think that doesn't necessarily
have to be quite that bad,
but I mean you really went to the end of
the scale immediately.
That's how extreme it was.
Yeah.
I was going for like,
you know,
just the idea of like someone is going
to kill someone that you care about and
you killed that person.
Yeah.
Because there are all these.
Like there's this trope in movies and tv
about,
you know,
like a cop shot,
someone that they had to shoot in the
line of duty.
It wasn't,
you know,
like just killing some kid.
It was,
you know,
shooting a bad guy and then they have to
go to therapy over it.
I feel like.
Yeah.
No.
Have you ever talked to soldiers about
that?
I haven't.
The real ptsd with soldiers is things
they can't control.
That's what really fucks with them.
Like worried about being attacked,
worried about being blown up,
worried about driving over an ied.
The soldiers that are proactive,
like Rangers,
Navy Seals,
guys go in and hunt people down.
They don't have that much ptsd,
PTSD.
There are different types of people.
I mean,
some of them have just been through
crazy firefights and they wake up with
horrible nightmares,
but a shocking amount of them realize
they're doing the right thing.
They have to do this,
this needs to be done.
And they're the man to do it.
Yeah.
And they're trained for it.
This is their job and they're all
together and they like a family.
It's a feel more superhero ask.
Yeah.
So when you see like a guy,
a cop and a movie that feels bad that he
had a shoot,
a bad guy.
That's like the writer,
that's the writer.
If the writer was a cop.
Yeah.
Or maybe a cop that maybe shouldn't be a
cop.
She was definitely some of those out
there.
Or a writer who shouldn't be a writer
or.
Right.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I mean those movies,
like how many of these movies have like
these,
like we're talking about the grooves
that are carved in that uh,
some people have that get depressed very
easily or behave really like really a
sad really easily.
Like those deals,
grooves,
those psychic grooves that they think
that they're supposed to behave like
that.
Those are carved into tropes and
storylines and plots.
And there's so many plots,
there's so many movies you watch,
like you didn't even write this.
Okay.
You knew what has already been written
about these subjects and you just sort
of repeated it with different words.
Yeah.
Like this isn't really a story you wrote
because this story has happened the
fucking million times in movies.
Well,
and it causes those stories existing
then cause people to act like that.
Yes.
Like we.
Yeah.
One of the most fascinating interviews I
ever saw was,
you know,
they interviewed the guy who was,
all the gangster movies in the forties
that say ha,
saying like all that.
And they said,
how did you get the accent so perfect.
And he said,
I made that accent up and then all the
gangsters wanted to be like the
gangsters in the movies.
And so then all the gangsters started
talking like that because of that,
because of those movies.
James Cagney.
Yeah.
Wow.
Like that was,
they just told the act like they just
started doing it.
Life Imitates Art,
right?
Yeah.
And then it's,
you know,
it's a.
and then people feel like,
oh,
well this is normal because that's what
we're shown on television.
Well that was the argument against
Gangsta rap that the argument was that
they were forcing kids by,
you know,
making this music really popular.
They're are forcing kids to accept this
type of behavior as being normal and
even exemplary,
like exemplary of a bad motherfucker.
You're shooting people and you ever go
back and listen to like the old Nwa.
Oh yeah.
I actually grew up.
So I grew up in Queens,
New York and I was big fan of old school
hip hop now.
I didn't like,
I was never big into the Nwa stuff.
I preferred,
you know,
the,
I preferred the lyrics about how great
we are at rapping,
not how many bitches we've killed,
but that was the,
that's kind of the line in the sand.
But who are your people?
Who would you like a tribe called quest?
I was,
so when five died.
I'm tribe guys are awesome.
Black sheep.
I'm a,
I loved a Pete Rock and cl smooth.
We a de la soul guy too.
Yeah,
just,
it was great.
I got to when I was 21,
I think I covered.
I was in college during the Seinfeld
sendoff party and the place where,
uh,
like the Tom's diner where monks was
based,
the exterior shot was like a block off
my campus.
So I made up a fake press pass and I
went and I covered the party and I got
to meet del Sol was there and it was
like,
it was so great.
That's nice.
Yeah.
You know,
it was a sad time for me,
man.
When Mc search got his own daytime talk
show,
I'm like,
God,
third base I used to love third base.
The end of goes the weasel visa goes
pistor gracile my eyes.
Someone hit my eye,
but if you watched the MC search,
a daytime talk show you like,
this can't be real.
He's punking us.
Yeah.
This is a character he's playing.
He's doing that Joaquin Phoenix thing
that Joaquin Phoenix did for a year.
It's that.
It's that same sort of thing.
When all of a sudden all the adults were
talking about the facebook and I'm like,
well,
facebook's done now.
Right?
You know,
this isn't going to be fun anymore.
It's MC search is done because he had
the most pre postures,
daytime talk show.
Did you ever watch it?
I know I knew about it,
but I never watched it.
Oh,
it was such and you know,
I mean,
he's like,
I'm a dead now,
but it was like play the beginning of it
because the beginning of the show,
see if he could find it because the
beginning of it is so fucking
preposterous when he explains how we're
gonna.
Keep it real.
We're keeping it real.
Oh,
there's no such thing as that.
Like when people say we're keeping it
real,
that means they're just.
They have no other words that they can
think of.
It's madness.
It's just,
it's,
it's a dangerous way of talking.
I was at a,
a I,
I did a bunch of extra work when I
started out and which,
that's so much fun.
That's,
Oh my God.
Extra work is the best because you get
to see just the worst in humanity right
in front of you with the extras.
They're absolute just batch it.
And there was a woman,
right?
Oh,
extrusion.
Between going back and forth from extra
work to open mics.
And that was my,
that was my day.
I would just go,
just go,
just watch,
just watch people desperately need
attention and do nothing of quality to
get it.
So there was this one woman,
they put out the craft services and this
one woman goes up and she loads up like
two plates and then putting stuff in her
purse also.
And I just,
she catches me looking at her and she
just goes,
I'm just keeping it real.
And I go,
well,
if you want to know what's real,
they're going to refill this table later
so you can just come get seconds if you
don't have product one and food to take
home though.
Well in the purse,
I understand.
But just the idea of it was just,
it was like the start of like a 14 hour
day just keeping it real.
I'm like,
that's not keeping it real.
Just say like,
Hey,
I'm really poor and I'm right now
keeping it real with me.
Dude.
Yeah.
The also that.
But you know,
it was something to stare at.
It was very weird.
That's a minor infraction.
You think about the world or holsters
and open mic and the paid furniture
world.
That's one of the.
Keeping it real things about the comedy
store.
You're constantly around crazy.
People Open Michart especially,
they're always hanging around,
you know,
because it's Kinda like a hangout on top
of being a club.
What's the craziest Shit you've seen?
Oh God.
I mean open mics or madness.
I mean there's [inaudible].
Anybody can get onstage and a lot of
times that's one of the things about
standup is that a lot of people don't
see themselves that way.
Other people see them.
Yeah,
and that gets exposed when you get
onstage because you realize,
oh,
this is how people see me.
People see me as being an obnoxious,
really annoying person that thinks
they're funny.
I see myself as being this really funny
person and then they have to work that
out over the.
I mean it's almost like a self
improvement course on communication
skills because you are brutally reminded
of how poor your communication skills
are when you don't get the laughs and
you're like,
God,
what is wrong with my thoughts?
This is my thought.
How about my friends think it's funny,
like what is it that's the only someone
who knows what's going on,
right?
The crazy people are the ones that go,
this card doesn't get me.
It was cropped sucks.
Yeah.
It's called bullshit.
I mean,
how many times have we heard that?
Just like every crowd I've ever played
to,
they all suck.
None of them understand bro,
but the worst thing that can happen,
one of those people is some one day
they'll just catch that magic wave where
you know there's this one crowd where
almost anyone can do well.
Yes,
there's these weird crowds that are just
so good and so hyped up at some with
really shitty skills can get up there
and just make it happen and they chased
the ghosts of that performance forever.
Here's a great story that I've told
before.
Unfortunately for people have heard it,
but Joey Diaz was the early days of the
compressor.
There was one woman who is insane.
I mean completely insane.
It just.
There was nothing remotely funny,
but anything she ever had to say,
she was brutal and she would go up and
every time she would go up,
everybody would have to get out of the
room.
It was just like,
what?
What is happening here?
How is she,
how does she even get spots?
It was during the nineties when it was
easier to get spots and so Joey Diaz
goes backstage behind the curtain and he
goes backstage and takes his pants off
and every time she hits a punchline he
opens up the curtain and chose the
crowd.
His balls,
she's got no pants on,
so every time she hits the punchlines,
he's doing this and she's killing.
I mean killing.
And you see that confident look in her
face.
She has no idea what's in the stride or
swagger and she hits those St punchlines
and all of a sudden Joe,
he comes out with his balls and
everybody's crying,
laughing and she,
she never knew.
She never knew.
She had no idea.
No one ever told her.
I don't think so.
If they did,
she would never believed
it.
Bull Shit.
I was Carolyn like she was just insane.
I tell.
I tell young comics that you don't,
you don't exist in the world.
How you see yourself,
you exist in the world as the sum total
of how everyone else sees you.
That's,
that's who you are and that's true on
stage.
Also,
you exist on that stage as the sum total
of how the crowd sees you,
right?
Your actions,
your what you wear,
how you stand,
how you speak.
Those can all determine that,
but your thoughts of how you want to be
seen,
the difference of how you see yourself
and how everyone else sees you,
that chasm is delusion and so the
shorter that chasm,
the more self aware you're going to be,
the funnier you can be.
The bigger that chasm,
the more likely you're going to flip a
table on a reality show.
Yes,
and that's the difference.
Very good point.
That's a very good,
very good way of putting it and it goes
back to what we were talking about
earlier that stand up in a lot of ways
is almost like a vehicle for
introspective observation.
Like you're.
You're almost forced to examine yourself
in a way that very few people do because
people like to put a blinders and that's
why people like to drink.
You just got to push it all away and
ignore all the faults and press on and
when you're doing standup,
I mean you really.
You can't do that because bombing is so
unbelievably,
brutally painful that you,
you go,
okay.
That can't happen again.
If you know you bomb though.
Like I try.
So the,
when I was first living out here,
uh,
I would hang out at the,
there were shows at Westwood Brewco all
the time.
I don't know if you ever did those Adam
Hunter shows?
No,
no,
no.
Adam prairie.
Well they were a,
so I would hang out there all the time
and there was one night where a bunch of
comics had done a show in Long Beach on
the Queen Mary and one by one they were
all getting to Westwood and every one of
them.
Man,
that show is terrible.
The Queen Mary's a boat by the way for.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
no.
Yeah.
I guess if people are unfamiliar and be
like,
they all performed on this one lady and
she's a Queen Queen of.
Well it's on the,
it's not even like in a bar called the
Queen Mary.
It's on the Queen Mary or what are they
talking about?
Yeah,
they just standing on this lady named
Mary.
And so one by one they would all show up
and they'd be like,
there were like 12 people there and it
was a nightmare and everyone is talking
about how shitty it was and how
everybody bombed and the night was
terrible.
Then one comment gets there and doesn't
know that everyone had already done
that.
And the first thing he does,
he had just got back from Long Beach.
Man,
I crushed that.
That was such a great show.
Everybody was going nuts and just going
on and on about how great it was.
And the rest of us are just being like,
Oh,
you've never killed.
Because if you think that that was
killing,
you've never killed.
You've never had a good show.
If you don't understand what that feels
like or you just lie and tell everybody
all the time.
You have good shows,
but it's terrible delusion.
Yeah.
They made me just doesn't understand
himself,
you know?
I mean,
how many guys have you met like that,
that like or that amount around girls or
around a job opportunity around.
It's true.
They think that they're way more
qualified for something.
There are like,
I'm going to go get this flight's
president job,
Bro.
I'm gonna.
Go get it.
I'm going to
run.
And there's a lot of people are just
completely crazy.
Well,
there's the eye.
I like to tell people,
you know,
follow your dreams and your dreams are
stupid because it's good advice if you
like.
If you quit your job to work at
American,
like to audition for American idol and
you've never ever been paid to sing
anywhere,
you're a fucking idiot.
Well,
American handles are really good example
because if you watched that show,
the best part about that show is the
beginning where you're just watching
mental illness.
They should call it a mental illness.
Our slash a shreds of talent.
Yeah.
Now because American illness,
for every one person that you get that
gets through the entire,
like who's like the big name stars that
have gone through American,
I'll carry on those.
Those two are huge and there's the guy
who went a little crazy.
The young country music,
gay guy.
Akin.
Yeah.
What happened to him?
I was actually in his true Hollywood
story.
I'm glad you said True Hollywood story
because if you said house the other
night.
No,
I was in a.
He was the guy who got me violently ill.
I know
clay aiken drugged me.
I was A.
I was making fun of him to a producer on
the show.
Oh boy.
Like she just told me that she was
working on that show and I was just
like,
what?
He was a friend of mine was like,
what are you up to?
Just telling me she's working on the
show.
And she goes,
yeah,
you know,
we were doing research on.
He used to be acquired boy.
And I just go,
oh.
So he started out with hymns and never
quite made it to hers.
And then she just goes,
you want to be on the show?
I was like,
what?
So then that line actually got cut by
the lawyers.
Yeah.
I had a,
I had five jokes that were in the script
and three of the five of them got cut by
the lawyers.
Fucking lawyers,
man.
That's why lawyers,
you can't have podcasts.
No,
you can't.
You're not allowed.
You fucks like a lawyer podcast.
They can't come on them,
they can't.
You can't have a lawyer telling you what
you can and can't say about podcasts.
You just,
you know,
loud because it's.
This is the last place is the last
bastion of free speech as far as like
just expressing yourself in
conversation.
There's no.
This is the only one left there.
Easily trick though.
I used to be.
I used to be a segment producer on a
show and we would always put in stuff we
didn't want to use so that they could
come in the room and be like,
no,
no.
You have to take that out,
take that out and then leave in the
thing that we thought they would take
out.
Well,
I'm sure you've seen the scene in team
America,
world police,
they the sex scene between the two
puppets,
they made like 10 minutes longer than
they wanted it to be where he shits on
her chest or she shits on his chest.
They pee on each side on both.
They went nuts and the reason why they
did it,
it was because they could cut some of
it.
It would still be preposterous.
Which it wound up being.
Yeah,
but that,
that's a common strategy that we did
that in the nineties with news radio,
we had an episode of news radio where
Phil Hartman said Penis on the air on
the radio show,
and then it was through the episode.
He said Penis like 20 times and they,
uh,
they were like,
you can't say penis more than eight
times.
And it was like eight times.
Who makes that it's fucking assholes.
Assholes,
assholes who decide what America is
willing to tolerate.
Crazy rebel bro.
I think it was four times,
but they,
uh,
they didn't air it so it didn't air.
It seems that at all.
No,
it had an air in like season two or
three,
like whatever season it was.
Maybe it was season two.
I don't remember what season it was,
but it,
it had an air leg the next season or the
season later.
And like we were told,
hey,
the penis episodes Aaron tonight.
We were all like,
what?
It's still never heard.
I never heard.
I love so much that there's something
called the penis episode,
by the way.
Good,
bad name the penis episodes.
Yeah,
that's good.
Bad name.
That would totally play at the whiskey.
Yeah,
like a fucking punk band.
The Penis Penis episode.
Yeah.
It's part of the patriarchy.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I think that,
uh,
I,
I used to call it a march of the
penguins because all the suits would
come down the hallway and tried to ruin
our art.
Uh,
but the idea that someone goes,
well,
it says specifically eight times,
you can say penis.
It's so hard
retread.
It's totally arbitrary and there's no
rules anywhere.
What happens on the nighttime,
like beetle juice comes out or penis
choose comes seat.
Satan comes through the floor.
There's a way to,
uh,
to do art.
And it's definitely not by having a
bunch of people that have money invested
in it,
looking at it going,
okay,
how can we maximize this?
How can we make this as sellable as
possible?
That's just the opposite of the kind of
mentality that you need to make
something good.
And if it just like you were talking
about with comedy or people don't see
themselves,
if you don't see yourself,
how other people see it's not going to
work and it won't be funny.
Well that's kind of the same thing with
art.
If you produce a television show or a
whatever it is and people don't enjoy it
while it won't go anywhere,
it'll fall off and then it's not good
anymore.
But to have someone come in and say,
Oh,
you got to do this and you got to do
that because we know better because
we're the ones with the money that never
works.
But every time,
every time I think that I remember that
according to Jim had over
100 episodes,
over a hundred episodes,
but that's.
There's a,
there's a style of comedy.
It had over a hundred episodes.
I remember Jag,
Jag was online,
I was on news radio and we were always
like,
what in the fuck is going on?
How is that a real show?
If you've ever watched that show?
Nobody watched that show.
And the people that did watch that show,
it's like they were sedated.
It's like it's a hum and under which
like subliminal messages were played in
the background about Bush being a great
president or something,
like it didn't make any vulcans and it
didn't make any sense that it stayed on
the air.
You watch any of the CSS or any of those
are the know the one I'm thinking of
Ntis.
So I,
I saw an episode the other day I get
transfixed with bad television.
Like I never put it on purpose,
but if like someone,
if I'm like in a hotel room or something
when I flip it on or whatever it is,
like it takes me a little to just shake
it off because I just want to be like,
how is this mate?
How is this possible?
You know?
And so I was watching it and I was
thinking like the comedy in it was so
bad.
Like the jokes were so terrible that I
almost wondered,
you know,
they hire people for punch up.
Do they hire people for punch down?
Like do they hire people to be like
water down these good job?
Well that's the chuck Lorre Guy.
He knows how to do them.
He knows how to do that drone that,
that one style of comedy,
like two and a half men.
Yeah,
he did a bunch of the white noise
machine.
He just does those things.
I
know that for people that are all just
like exhausted from eating carbs and
sugar all day and they just sitting in
the couch of some melting.
Then the dumbest fucking humor plays out
in front of them and it's just enough to
keep them paying attention.
So they watched those Toyota
commercials.
I,
I was,
you know,
very often I wonder about like how does
this get made?
How is this,
why does anybody like this,
et cetera.
And I was at some truck stop in the
middle of nowhere,
just getting gas and getting food and
there's a tier of the TV playing.
It was like a little lunch counter and
there's a TV playing and as a commercial
and there's this guy running around.
It's for blinds,
but this guy is running around.
He like tries to open those blinds,
Kinda has nothing to do with it.
And then he runs outside and you get
stung by a bunch of stung by a bunch of
bs and he's like fighting them off.
And I'm sitting there thinking like,
oh,
what the fuck?
Who the fuck would do?
I can write commercials like,
who would do that?
And there's a dude sitting next to me
just going,
he's,
he can't get away from the bees like
just out loud to know what to know.
One just like he's all over it.
They're all over the zoo.
It's for,
oh,
it was at my friend's house once and her
friend and her mom was over and uh,
they were watching like some spiderman
movie and Spiderman got bit by a spider
and she just goes,
he got bit by a spider will never,
I'll never forget that.
Never forget to go.
He got bit by a spider like I gotta get
Outta here.
Just one of these things the rest of us
didn't see.
There's just something about like,
man,
I just think just like you can buy a
prius or you could buy a shelby gt,
500,
you know,
one one has 100 horsepower,
one has 500 horsepower.
Brains are like that too.
They just have to be.
There's just no doubt about it.
And there's a lot of those little prius
brains out there,
man.
And if you put on a show for Prius
brains,
you will attract them like,
like metal to a magnet.
Just
find it.
Those,
those,
the duck dynasty shows you ever watch
duck dynasty?
I have thankfully not even seen a
clinic.
Shit.
Fucking watch it for sure.
Just to understand that there's people
like that out there that look forward to
it.
I got to Dvr.
I said,
you know,
I heard what today they're going to do.
Shoot some ducks.
She won't use them.
Duck duck show,
duck.
And they shoot it.
They don't even shoot it.
Hardly.
Shoot ducks show is more about like
horrible people hanging out doing really
boring
shit and locked.
They're all down home.
They're down home their country.
That's why.
That's why the people who like when the
people say like,
Oh,
you know,
I voted for Bush because I can,
he reminded me of me and I'm just like,
when you're a fucking asshole.
Also,
like,
you're also like to think you reminded
them of them.
Yeah.
It was your dad a multimillionaire and
did you grow up in Maine and pretend you
from Texas?
Like what about him?
What about the fact that your dad was
your dad in the CIA to where you see
that you see that with trump now where
people are like,
oh,
he reminds me of me and I'm just like,
he the furthest thing from you?
He's the,
he's the.
I grew up in New York City and so like I
remember I was a kid when it happened,
but I remember the central park jogger
when trump took out for full page ads in
different newspapers calling for the
death penalty for these black kids who
didn't even do it and he was just
inciting a riot.
Basically.
He was just trying to race bait and get
attention and that's the guy I remember.
No,
I don't relate to that guy.
Yeah,
he's a real tough guy to relate to.
I don't think people really do relate to
them.
I think what they relate to is the
possibility that he may win and they
like to be on the camp of a winner.
So like a football team that they can
get behind.
They don't really give a shit about the
players.
They just decide we're going to win.
We're fucking winning.
We're winning.
We're trump trump's winning.
But the trump winning all those
dickheads.
Yeah,
they.
But they also say the things like,
you know,
like he speaks like I do,
like that's,
I don't want a president who speaks
like,
and I do feel fairly intelligent guy.
I want my president to be wasting harder
than me.
I would like a really articulate Obama
type guy,
but that didn't work out.
Yeah.
Had the Obama type guy was like,
what we were hoping for.
Like when,
when Bush was in office,
Obama was like,
the fucking recipe man.
We want a black guy who's super
articulate,
really intelligent and well,
we're kind of relax.
Everybody would always race bullshit.
Look,
clearly,
it has nothing to do with race,
it's about culture and circumstances and
where are you growing up?
Look at this guy.
He's black.
He's smarter than all of us were.
Good luck.
He's liberal.
He's going to fix everything.
He's going to relax everybody.
He doesn't want to.
Guantanamo Bay wants to get us out of
Iraq.
We made it through this Bush thing.
We didn't.
Civilization collapsed and then he's an
office in his own.
It was kind of the same shit.
He talks better.
Yeah,
that's kind of the same shit is going
on.
I think the biggest problem is that he's
too reasonable,
like he's too reasonable and the people
who disagree with him or being
completely unreasonable and you can't
just be like,
well,
let's look at both sides.
If one side is being a Dick,
you don't look at.
It's like CNN will do that.
Where they're like,
well,
let's present both sides of this
argument.
Here's one person against pedophilia,
so let's talk to someone who's for
pedophilia.
And it's like,
no,
don't give that guy airtime.
Right.
Don't ever talk to that guy.
Yeah.
So.
So the people who you know,
who want to take rights away and who
want to convince poor people to vote
against their own best interests,
like you don't give them equal time,
but they do well.
The problem is you're dealing with right
and left and then again,
people get really tribal.
Yeah.
When they're on a team,
they get super tribal,
like I told,
told us before.
But it's always struck me as being
really bizarre.
I was with a buddy of mine is a writer
and he was talking about the election.
He's like,
we have to win in Idaho if we went in
Idaho or Iowa.
We went in Iowa,
we got it wrapped up.
I was like,
what is this?
We,
I guess as we shit,
it's like the Democrats.
So I'm like,
okay,
you're on a team,
right?
You're on a team,
you're fucking.
This is the mariners,
this is the marriage versus the raiders.
You've got your,
you've got this weird team mentality.
And I think that's entirely one of the
things that is real comfortable for
people to fall into when it comes to
elections.
And it's one of the reasons why I think
we need way more parties,
at least at least that way we'll have
more teams because this one is two team
option is like if every fucking year it
was a celtics versus the Lakers in the
NBA finals game,
wouldn't you be tired of that after
awhile?
Well that's I think how America feels
about the election.
That's why the ratings are down.
That's why people aren't really paying
attention that much.
That's why people are so frustrated by
the choices.
Like you can't be kind of just two
choices.
Well I used to be,
you know,
very politically minded and,
and active.
And I used to do a lot of like everybody
should go out and vote and then I talked
to more and more people and then I'm
just like,
not everybody.
Yeah.
Well it would be nice if we didn't have
a representative government.
Yeah,
it would be nice.
First of all,
if you didn't have like one like super
delegates,
what is that?
What do you mean you don't have to vote
for the people that you're Stateville
superdelegates were basically to keep
Jesse Jackson out of office.
Like that's,
that's how they started.
Really?
Yeah.
When Jesse Jackson was starting to get
some heat and I think it was 1980,
uh,
suddenly there was 80 or 84,
I forget,
but it was a suddenly superdelegates
came out,
but good job.
Super d'elegance kept that fucking demon
out of the White House.
Not only super delegates though,
but even the delegates of the electoral
college,
they don't have to vote the way their
constituents do.
In fact,
there was a time when one of them,
I think it was in Minnesota,
accidentally wrote down the name of the
vice president in both slots for
president,
vice president.
So his vote didn't count and that was
like 30,000 people that he was
representing.
Whoa.
And just because he was a fucking idiot.
And like you,
you can actually,
if you're now obviously people wouldn't
do it for the most part because you'd
think,
oh well then they lose the ability to do
it and that's all the little power they
have in their life is to be a delegate
at this convention.
But the fact of the matter is that like
New York state can vote 100 percent for
a Democrat and then the electoral
college can go and just vote for
Republican.
It can just,
they can do it if they want to or vote
for a Democrat,
they can write someone in if they want
to.
It's a ridiculous idea that was
conceived back when you were in.
You couldn't communicate with people
easily.
Yeah.
It was that simple.
It was the point of it was that like not
everyone was qualified to vote because
you didn't hear things.
Yes.
And so they would be like,
well,
here's the representative government.
They'll,
you know,
learn from what their people want.
And then they'll take that over there.
And it was a wonderful idea.
And now it's bullshit.
Yeah,
it's ridiculous.
And it's time has gone.
I mean,
we,
if we,
this is the point that I always bring
up,
if we didn't have a system of government
in place,
we had all these people.
We all just woke up today who would say
we need one person to run it.
No one who would say that we need one
person to be representative of the state
because the people can't tell everybody
know,
will you have an email now?
We have twitter,
we have facebook,
we have poles,
we have.
There's ways to find out what people
want and people don't want to.
Representative government in 2016 is
like writing with feathers.
It's like some old stupid shit that we
don't need anymore.
We should make them right with feathers.
Who should make them wear powdered wigs
to those fucks.
Yeah.
Feel like you want this office while it
comes with a couple of things.
I mean if you want to be like one of
those people,
you should dress like one of those
people that invented it.
Then there'd be no hillary email scandal
because it would just be like maybe she
wrote on the wrong kind of parchment.
Yeah,
she wrote on the actual animal skins and
said,
we don't do that anymore.
Hillary,
you're doing old school.
She's doing old school with her non
encrypted email,
right?
Yeah.
Have you talked about,
I assume you've talked about the gorilla
already.
Yeah,
we kind of talked about it a little.
Did we think we did?
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
Yeah,
it's fucked up for the zoo.
The zoo fucked up.
You shouldn't make it so God damn easy
to get in the gorilla tank.
Yeah,
it.
So on this one,
I don't know exactly what happened on
this one cause I'm,
I'm trying to kind of block it out.
I saw the whole thing so that the kid
kid fell in.
Was it,
was it like a kid falling in where the
parent was at fault or was it a kid
doing something they shouldn't have
done?
Well,
the kid was doing something and
shouldn't have done,
but the parents weren't watching the
kid.
Yeah.
Look,
the zoo made it way too easy to get into
the grill and closure.
The kid got through the fence,
fell down into this water.
The gorilla came in and scooped up.
The kid arguably saved the kid but was
handling it in a way that it could
handle a gorilla baby,
but a human baby,
you just ripped the arms off the kid.
He could really,
really hurt it and I just don't think a
gorilla is even aware of how fragile a
three year old human being is as opposed
to.
Have you ever had a three year old champ
or three year old girl in near you?
A.
I can't say I've ever had that
experience.
I was on a TV show.
It was on his radio and they brought in
a champ for a scene in this two year old
chimp with a diaper on was like I was
holding it and it was was beating on me.
It was like hit me in the back,
like playing around with me.
They're unbelievably strong and sinewy
like a little tiny bodybuilder.
Like they don't feel like a baby.
Like I have little kids and when you
pick up a little kid,
they're all soft and they feel like
little kids,
they're,
they're mushy.
This just champ was not mushy and I
think this gorilla probably had no idea
how to handle a baby softly,
you know,
probably our toddler really didn't,
didn't know.
And they panicked and then they shot the
gorilla.
But it seems to me that there's gotta be
a better way to do that.
But I could see the parents being,
fuck that gorilla,
shoot it,
shoot it.
I want my kid back.
Yeah.
But I could see the gorilla being like,
fuck those parents.
Yeah.
But I like people more than I like
gorillas.
I do.
And I love your joke about team people.
You know,
it's,
it's.
I mean it's a,
it's a bit I,
I enjoy,
but there was a there.
So there was a bit I used to do.
There was a store in Chicago like 15
years ago where a woman was holding her
baby over gorilla pit.
Oh yeah.
I remember that.
Like holding it straight up and then
drop the baby and on that one the
gorilla saved the kid and picked it up
and,
and kept until the zookeeper could give
it back to the mother.
And the joke I used to do is be like,
I'm sorry,
give it back.
Like at that point,
a gorilla is a better parent than the
person who wants you voluntarily dangle
your baby over a wild animal.
It's death you giving of the baby away.
Well,
we've even made it
way too easy for people to survive.
People survived very little adversity.
We survive with.
It's easy access to food,
easy access to employment.
If you get fired,
you get to sue.
If you're incompetent completely,
you can claim that you were harassed at
work.
There's so many loopholes and it's so.
We're so nerfed.
Every sharp edge is covered with foam
and everyone's wearing a helmet.
The nerfing of America,
and this is what we got left.
We've got these fucking idiots.
We've got a bunch of really dumb people
that are allowed to fuck and have kids.
And you can't stop people from having
kids because then someone can try to
stop you.
Well,
I don't like your belief,
Steve Hofstetter.
You're a crazy liberal.
You think you should.
I think you should be able to have a
nation that's not under God and you're
gonna raise your children without God.
That's child abuse and then you on my
show the other day,
nobody shows,
but you know,
I just think they're human beings need a
certain amount of adversity.
We need a certain amount of difficulty
to overcome to learn those lessons,
to filter that experience down into your
behavior and when you don't learn those
lessons and you just live this muted,
nerved up world,
then you're holding your fucking baby
over the gorilla tank because you
getting a little thrill.
Who's,
whoops,
I'm dumb.
I dropped the baby.
Just like you drop your cell phone just
like you drop your keys and the fucking
drainage ditch.
You're a dummy.
You drop shit.
You're a stupid fuck.
And not supposed to be alive.
Should have been eaten by wolves.
Hundreds of years ago.
The world was safe.
You would have been the one who walked
off the trail.
I'm going to go find a better word to
the council and the wolf's would have
eaten you and no one would have heard
from you.
And that's what it's supposed to happen
to those types of people.
Well
it is Darwin.
I'm a big fan.
Big Fan.
He had some good ideas.
Chris bowers,
I don't know if you know him.
He's a comic out of.
Oh,
you've worked more days.
So,
uh,
in Indianapolis.
Yeah.
Chris and I are two of the owners.
Oh yeah.
No Shit.
Yeah,
what a great club.
That's awesome man.
It's even better.
We had new location now.
Oh no shit.
You guys moved A.
Yeah,
we have a balcony and everything now.
It's great.
It's like a,
it like a small theater.
Oh,
that's terrific man.
That was a great club.
No,
that was a fun one.
Everybody loves that place.
That's cool though.
I didn't know you own that place.
Yeah.
Good for you.
You fucking entrepreneur as well.
Uh,
so bowers has a great theory where,
you know,
the,
the way to I guess,
prevent the stupid people in the
overpopulation is if everyone is
basically sterilized and you have to
take something in order to be able to be
pregnant.
But the only way you get that pill is
you have to take that pill every day.
You don't take a pill to stop yourself
from being pregnant.
You take a pill to get yourself
pregnant,
so you have to take that pill.
Both partners would have to take that
pill every day for six months because if
you can't commit to taking a pill every
day for six months,
you can't raise a kid.
Yeah,
but it's so easy for people to just do
that.
That's not.
That's not enough of a fucking start.
It should be like one of those crows
have to get a crumb out of a tube and
they have to use one tool to get the
other tool to get the third tool.
That's how it should be.
It's too fucking easy.
Just take a pill.
You should have to do a puzzle everyday.
That should give you a puzzle,
and if you fail creasing difficult,
you don't get a pill,
so you get six months of correct answers
to puzzles to get your pills.
That's the only way she'd be able to get
your pills.
I think that's how chipotle,
he gave away free Burrito once on their
annual anniversary.
If they did it that way for people the
fucking four.
Oh,
five would be a breeze.
Yeah,
it would be nobody just be a couple
people waving at each other.
We made it.
You ever watch you ever watch like a
period piece?
Television where they run into people
they know like,
like a mad men.
They would always like run into people
at the restaurant that they would know
and part of me is like,
oh,
well that's convenient.
Then I'm like,
no,
no.
There are fewer people.
There were fewer people then it was.
It seems.
It seems possible.
It's definitely possible.
It was possible in the nineties when I
moved here in 1994,
there was half as many people.
I wonder what the actual statistic was,
but I'm pretty sure is half as many
people like when you would get,
you'd get on the highway and the traffic
would be bad,
but it wouldn't be that bad.
Would be no big deal.
I remember people talking about getting
from Santa Monica to the valley in 10
minutes.
What exactly?
Ten minutes,
that's what it wanted to drive a
Delorean,
regular car.
Just get in your car and drive.
And this back when cars were slow as
shit and the brakes were terrible.
There was no traffic.
You just get around.
It's only nine miles.
No problem.
They just did it.
It's the same as a a,
you know,
planes.
I mean I've only been flying about 20
years but 20 years ago and now that's
part of because they do the spoke
garbage now where they,
you know,
you have to fly through Cincinnati to go
to Denver or whatever it is.
But it's,
everything's full.
Every single flight is full.
Like the idea when someone doesn't have
a seat next to you on if it's a
Christmas party.
Oh yeah.
Well how about when they say,
we've oversold this flight,
we're looking for volunteers.
What do you,
you're selling some shit.
You don't even really have.
They absolutely do that.
But in fairness,
we can do that with comedy clubs too
because there's always a percentage of
no shows.
So there's,
do we,
do you do that at mortise?
Uh,
we've,
we've done it,
but it's not by a high percentage,
it's like because usually our no show
percentage will be like 10 percent,
so will oversell by like five percent
because people,
because if you have 100 people,
10 people won't show up.
It depends on the price of the ticket.
It depends on the act like with,
with a celebrity,
no show percentages of virtually
nothing.
But with like a typical day,
you know,
at a typical,
like a,
we call it a just funny,
someone who's good but no one has heard
of them.
Right.
You know,
plenty of times some will be like,
oh yeah,
let's get four tickets to the club and
then they only have one friend like that
happens all the time.
Babysitter canceled.
That's true.
You know,
it's too rainy out.
Someone doesn't want to go.
There are a ton,
tons of reasons,
but you can't fuck over the people that
actually paid and actually showed up.
Never once,
not one time that you have extra chairs,
you can just shove them in places in
case everybody shows up if we have to.
But what happens is on the ticket it
very specifically says like,
this is good until showtime.
Oh,
okay.
And so what happens is,
even if there is,
even if the no show rate is way less
than it is,
even if there's weird anomaly where the
no show rate is like zero,
there are still people who come late and
you can't come late.
Yeah.
If you come late,
like you might get turned away.
And we tell everyone that even if you
have a ticket,
we tell everyone that if you come late
you can get turned away.
What if you get stuck in drama?
Well,
you can call.
You can call and say,
hey,
you know,
we're on our way and please hold a seat
that seems reasonable.
But like that thing about it this way
with Broadway,
the doors close.
Okay?
First of all,
fuck Broadway,
all that nonsense.
Fuck musicals and fuck plays.
Okay,
we have movies now.
I want special effects.
I don't want you talking loud.
I'm with you.
I want you miked up.
I want you to be able to whisper and I
want to hear it crystal clear and I'm
giving you no leeway.
I'm giving you no leeway because the
costumes are nice.
Yes.
I won't plan.
I want writing.
I want to fucking.
I want new shit to want some old shit
that doesn't apply anymore.
I'm okay with musicals.
I don't,
you know,
I can just suspend my disbelief and go.
Okay.
Everybody's singing fine.
I mean,
but it's got to be a good song.
It's got a further the plot.
It can't just be something that they
know is going to sell.
Well,
yeah.
I went to a musical.
Well I should take that back because the
book of Mormon is fucking amazing.
Yes.
That's a musical.
That's what I mean.
But those guys are just,
they do everything right.
They just do everything right.
But that was also Bobby Lopez who did
avenue Q.
I don't know who that is.
I don't know what that is.
Do you don't know avenue q?
Nope.
So avenue q is the other good Broadway
show in of the two.
Uh,
avenue q was the one where the,
they had songs,
uh,
the Internet is for porn and everyone's
a little bit racist.
Oh,
okay.
It's cool.
So it's a good study.
Long as it's common puppets.
Yeah,
it was with puppets.
It was like a Broadway show with
puppets,
like sesame street on Broadway.
Hey,
whatever happened to the fucking
spiderman Broadway show where people
kept falling on their head.
Did they abandoned that?
Uh,
it,
yeah,
eventually,
yes.
Spiderman turned off the dark eventually
turned on the dark because people were
dying,
right.
People get paralyzed and shit and they
will fell.
So my,
my,
uh,
my wife worked at a audience awards
which is like a frequent flyer points
for Broadway and so she would go to all
these shows and so she went to spiderman
like during the previews and she texted
me and she goes,
one of the actors has been stuck for an
hour,
like just on the rope.
Oh my God.
And she just said,
yeah,
he's been stuck for an hour.
And I was like,
I bet you know how he feels like it's
just,
it was her.
She would go to all these shows and
eventually like I wouldn't have to go
anymore because she took me to a
American idiot.
And did you ever see that?
The Green Day One?
No.
So I like Green Day.
How dare you.
I,
I enjoy that song specifically.
I wish Joey Diaz was here right now
because he would,
he would murder milking you?
Well,
I,
I like,
I like the song American idiot because
it caused people who it was about to,
to enjoy it without knowing it was about
them.
I liked the diversity of that,
but the musical was,
it was like when I was 30 seconds in
before I was like,
Oh fuck this show.
It was like watching the best painters
in the world tried to play football.
It was horrific because like that's a
funny way of putting it.
Well,
I know that,
I know that like green day isn't like
real,
you know,
punk punk,
but at the same time that's what the
movement it came out of and it's
supposed to be anti establishment and
the whole point of the show,
I mean,
the Broadway thing of it basically made
it like everybody's just jazz hands to
fucking green.
It was ridiculous.
Kind of showed what green day really is
all about.
Look at this green day was,
it's,
it's a manufactured outrage.
I was so disappointed because afterward
I was like,
I can't believe they lend their name to
this.
And then I looked it up and I go,
oh no,
they were in charge.
It's like,
that's it.
That's the end of it for me.
That's why everybody was correct.
And I think that's one of those things
where like people look at the,
look on that guy's say that jared from
subway,
like who is that?
Oh No,
it's Penn Jillette's younger brother,
doesn't it look like?
And that wasn't even a molestation.
Joe Couple cigars on the far right with
the two tone hair and the conveniently
placed tattoos.
I bet he's annoying.
Yeah,
I bet.
In his last play he played like a
salesman.
How about the guy with the flannel
shirt?
Is that a flannel shirt or a jacket?
It's a blazer.
It's a flannel blazer to.
He's the drummer for green.
Yeah,
that's Christ.
Take that picture off job.
Take it off.
Yeah,
man.
There's a lot of that stuff.
You know,
it's like,
it's like what we're talking about.
We're talking about suits coming in and
telling you what you can and can't say.
I mean they're doing their being their
own suits.
They're trying to formulate something
that they think America is going to
absorb and then they're thinking about
buying yachts.
So avenue q is a great show,
but the most fun part of watching it was
watching the old Broadway people
thinking that they're super naughty for
going to the show just like these,
like 60,
70 year old women who like just couldn't
believe.
Like they said,
masturbation.
Like just.
Yeah,
that was kind of.
I had fun watching people watch it.
Well,
if I was going to go to Broadway,
that would be kind of why.
I would go,
I would go to people watch the really
upper crust rich crowd of Manhattan
Nights,
the people that have homes in the
Hamptons,
like those people that go to all those
Broadway shows and that's their social
life.
That's what they do.
They go to parties,
they dress really well,
they eat really well and they go to the
finest restaurants in town.
They always get a table at the finest
restaurants and here they are and it's
like that's like their hobby is being
rich and doing rich people things and if
you want to be cultured,
you have to read the New York Times,
you have to read the New Yorker and you
have to go to these musicals when they
come out and you have to go to Broadway.
When it comes out there's a new player.
You're going to be there.
Yes we are.
We have season tickets to the Broadway
or whatever the fuck.
They have season tickets to Broadway.
Yeah,
they can't.
They do.
They're like multi ticket packages.
There's a.
those people have to do everything they
can to be cultured,
except actually talk to human beings.
Well,
they talked to a few human beings who
are exactly like them.
Yeah.
But they don't talk to anyone who,
you know what I mean?
They might,
they might know their gardener's name.
Well,
there's a bunch of people that are like
that,
that are just completely locked up and
consumption and that's the only thing
that they can discuss.
I had this neighbor,
I used to call them bling bling because
a bling bling always had,
like everything was shiny.
He always had like expensive watches and
they always had the nicest cars.
I couldn't talk to the guy about
anything other than like cars and
houses,
you know,
like I would say,
hey man,
how you doing?
Good.
Good,
good to see what that guy did.
His house looks like Shit.
W what year is our car?
Like?
That's all he would talk about while he
was into was consumption.
What was good for the property values?
Uh,
where did you get to watch?
Oh,
nice.
Nice Watch.
Like,
that was all he was into acquiring
items,
moving items around fixing items,
making items better.
But this was,
he was the American idiot.
I mean,
he,
he was locked into that.
I mean,
I knew this guy for years.
I mean literally that is why I called
them blink,
blink.
We'd never had a conversation about
anything other than objects that he
wanted or objects that he saw that he
liked.
I mean,
it was really weird,
but there's a lot of people like that
out there.
Especially really rich people.
Yeah.
The uh,
when people make this argument about
like,
oh,
well,
you know,
we have to allow the rich to be able to
spend their money because it's for the
economy and that's why they shouldn't,
you know,
we shouldn't have higher taxes on the
rich.
I'm just like DC.
How they,
how they spend it.
Do you see the,
the ridiculousness that that has been
like it's the problem with higher taxes
on the rich,
is that like what,
what,
what is,
what's going on?
What is capitalism like?
What is it?
Is it a game?
And we'd try to.
I mean,
if one person works harder and they make
more money and one person a is more
innovative,
they're more creative,
they figured out a way to extract more
money from the.
Should they
be penalized?
I mean,
aren't we all trying to do that?
Are we all trying to acquire money in
some way,
shape or form?
And who is to say that one person,
some Bill Gates type guy is better at it
so they should be penalized.
Like it seems like you're trying to rig
the game because someone has just way
fucking better at it.
Well,
I think the problem is that it's not.
I don't have a problem with people who
are better at it.
I have a problem with the people who are
the grandson of the person who was
better at it.
Exactly.
That was just,
just the idea of like,
oh,
you know,
my uh,
my father's father's sperm was real
innovative.
The Heinz account has always had good
merit here.
Yeah.
That kind of stuff.
I inherited some.
Money's a,
that's a tricky one.
I don't think it's bad for the people
that get it.
Yeah.
I look at the,
uh,
um,
I look at the people who,
there's that quote that I forget where
it's from,
but that quote that America is a nation
of temporarily embarrassed millionaires
that like everyone thinks that they're a
millionaire there just going through
hard times right now.
I get it.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the reasons why poor
people vote for Republicans.
Yeah.
They really think,
well,
you need business new businesses who is
more anti poor people than Republicans,
but how many poor people wind up being
conservative?
It's like,
what I want to say to those people is
like,
I get,
you know,
we all want to be millionaires.
We all want to be successful and that's
wonderful and we need a path to get
there and that's fantastic.
But tell me this,
when you were 55 and you were working at
applebee's,
what the fuck is your path?
Where from here to there?
You tell me.
You tell me what app you're going to
invent.
You tell me what you know you're going
to win on American idol as the old lady
like you tell me how the fuck are you
going to go from the lowest tax bracket
to the highest one when you're already
55 and your dream has gone,
but it can happen.
See to say that it's kind of silly
because we've.
There's been a million stories about
like someone who writes a book in their
fifties and they become rich.
I mean all that stuff has happened.
It's just a matter of you,
but you have to do it.
Whatever it is,
you have to do it.
If you're actually just taking all your
time and you're staying at applebee's
and then you're drinking and then you
watch the TV and any falling asleep.
That pattern.
Yeah.
If that person said to me while I've
been working on this novel for a very
long time and I have a lot of faith in
and I've sent it to a lot of publishers
and you know what?
I've been rejected a lot of times,
but I'm not going to take no for an
answer and going to pound the pavement
and where to find it.
Maybe I'll self publish at my,
you know,
and I'll,
and I'll walk around and I'll go to
libraries.
You know what?
And I'll,
I'll get my book in libraries and,
and if they said all that,
I'd be like,
you know what?
Don't pay taxes.
Yes.
Vote Republican.
But if they're just like,
well,
you know,
my,
my brother's got this idea,
right?
My brother's got this idea,
now it,
he just needs a little bit of seed
money.
It's a little bit of seed money.
That person.
I'm just like,
I don't understand why you're voting
against your own best interest.
Well,
I don't think they think they are.
They think that people are lazy.
I work hard.
Got Damn Lazy People.
They want that welfare money.
They're going to take that welfare.
Just spend it on cigarettes.
Yeah.
Well,
the,
the uh,
I love during,
during
the a debt,
you know,
the recession,
the collapse when everybody was talking
about like,
I don't like how the government spends
my money,
like the government spends money on
things they can't afford.
I'm like,
you just lost your house in your car
because you bought something you
couldn't afford.
Yeah.
But they thought they could afford it.
Right.
Just stupid.
Like the problem with those goddamn
mortgages,
man.
Yeah.
That was the craziest Ponzi scheme ever.
That you would have someone with an
adjustable rate mortgage and all of a
sudden the rate gets jacked up through
the roof and you're paying three times
as much.
Like,
what did I sign up for?
Wait a minute.
I was only paying $1,500 a month and now
I'm paying 15,000.
There is,
there is a great deal of deception and
fraud and garbage that was done from the
banks and from the people in charge.
But there was also a great deal of
people just didn't want to do their
homework and they just,
yeah,
they heard something too good to be true
and they didn't know the lesson of if
it's too good to be true,
it's not true.
Yeah,
definitely.
It's the same people who like,
they'll open up the email,
they'll be like,
what?
What do you,
what do you mean I got this email,
we're all,
I get all this money.
I just click on this link right here
from this person I never met.
Like how do you not know?
The first time I saw that I was like,
this looks wrong.
Well you're a smart Guy Steve.
But that's what I'm saying.
Like there's people,
they're dumb.
It's so difficult.
So lonely.
The top of Olympus.
Well,
one of the things we were talking about
earlier about debt and about people with
credit card debt that they don't realize
it.
And if you had money,
I cash money and you wouldn't,
you wouldn't be so likely to go into
debt with cash.
Yeah.
Well I think that's the same thing with
the environment.
I think the environment is almost like
credit because it's like throwing
garbage out the window and no one's
thinking about it.
We're burning fossil fuels and fucking
spraying hairspray into this guy.
No one's thinking about what that's
doing because we don't feel it instantly
and immediately.
We don't have like a vault.
We open up shit.
I'm out of air.
You know,
I'm running low
on fish left.
Yeah,
we don't feel it.
So we continue to act in the exact same
way because we're not really getting the
feedback.
You know,
you watch an inconvenient truth.
You went,
well,
that's Kinda fucked up.
Oh God.
I get to work in the morning,
click,
shut it off,
go to bed.
She abb up,
wake up,
keep going.
And that's a pattern that just kept,
keeps getting repeated and repeated and
we're not feeling the feedback of the
negative actions.
I was uh,
I was flying and it was during that
crazy winter with a polar vortex stuff
where it was like negative two degrees
and a lot of places and it got down to
like negative 20 in the Midwest.
What year was that?
Two years ago.
I think two,
three years ago,
yeah,
it was a,
I know in La we're just like,
yeah,
got all the way down to 55.
It was terrible.
And so,
um,
I,
yeah,
I got woken up by the bells of the ice
cream truck.
It was really a difficult winter,
but the,
um,
but so I'm,
I'm flying somewhere and there's this
guy,
you know,
going through a in front of me and Tsa
and,
you know,
he's taking off his coat and all that
stuff.
And Tsa got a cold,
isn't it one of these small
airports where they all went to high
school together and uh,
and the guy goes so much for global
warming and I,
I need to leave well enough alone.
I need to learn how to do that.
But I was just like,
I was like,
oh,
actually,
you know,
global warming also makes it colder in
the winter.
The Jews,
he knew right away.
And uh,
yeah,
he just,
immediately he was,
he just what he,
his reaction actually was one of my
favorite things anyone's ever said.
He just goes,
that's what they want you to believe.
Oh,
like they do because they're scientists
and they want you to believe them.
Well,
Sam Harris was talking about this
yesterday that trump is a global warming
denier.
Yeah.
Global warming denier is really close to
being the president of United States.
He's not only is he global warming
denier,
but the good news is if he felt he would
make money off of it,
he would believe in global warming.
Oh yeah.
For sure.
There's no platform.
He can't believe him.
Wonder what the thought process behind
that is.
Just plow straight ahead and just do
whatever's good for you and don't give a
fuck or is there like.
It's narcissism tists.
We'll figure it out.
Yeah,
for sure.
Right.
That's really what it was answered my
own question.
I think it's.
I think it's A.
Yeah,
it's what you were saying.
The idea of like planning ahead and not
know like I have this thing where it
bothers me when someone's unhappy.
Like Jane,
when I can see on happiness,
whether someone's mad at me about
something I did or just someone's sad,
like immediately I'm like,
I have to fix this.
You know,
like,
I don't know what that's from,
I don't know how I got that way and I
try to get over it to a degree.
I like being compassionate,
but I also don't want it to like totally
ruined me and I think that there are
people who are wired and completely the
other direction who they can walk by,
someone bleeding to death and just be
like,
ugh.
The sidewalk used to be so much nicer.
Yeah.
I guess that's probably like the type of
person that you don't want an office.
Yes.
That's the exact type of person you
don't put no,
but you also don't want the type of
person in the office is constantly
worried about people being sad because
then you'll never get anything done
because it's 300 million people and at
least 30 million of them are satisfied.
Fuck,
right.
The least.
I can look at statistics being sad all
day with no problem.
Oh,
statistics don't fuck with you.
It's actually humans.
It's,
it's the interaction with humans.
What about puppies?
I'm a big dog rescue guy.
Oh,
me too.
So I actually go to the fucking.
I can't go.
I'll take them all.
Dude.
On this past,
on this past tour I did in 10 days.
In 10 days I stopped and got for strays.
I didn't keep them,
but I like helped rescue for sure in 10
days.
Just driving around.
We found them on the street for strays
in 10 days.
You know,
they were actually straight.
I didn't know.
People don't just like let their dogs
out,
the dogs come back.
I used to have a dog like that.
Well,
one of them was,
if it hadn't come back,
I mean if it was laid out,
it had been a couple of days,
like it was like mad it up and
everything.
I'm,
one of them was actually someone who
like was someone who just keeps their
door open and then their was just
playing in traffic
and.
But thankfully it to end,
he comes out and he goes,
I've been looking for him and I just go
where
you can a shit.
Where's the dog?
Uh,
the third one was one who was,
I don't think she's ever been owned.
It was just on the streets of Louisville
and just walking around near the airport
and then the fourth one was actually one
where this was the one that made me the
most upset because leash and collar
right outside of a dog grooming place.
So I'm like,
Oh shit.
One got out and so this is in Phoenix
and I'm running around.
It's 95 degree heat and this dog is fast
and I'm like running around trying to
chase it.
And finally there's this alcove in the
shopping center where it goes in the
alcove and I'm like,
great.
It'll be cornered.
I'll finally be able to get it.
And so I go in there and there's like a
woman with a stroller and I go,
Hey,
do you see a stray dog run by here?
And then I see the dog in the corner and
I go,
oh,
it's right there.
And she goes,
that's my dog because that's your dog.
I've been chasing it for 20 minutes
through a parking lot.
It almost got hit by three different
cars.
And she goes,
Oh,
did it?
Like,
yeah.
That's what happens when dogs run around
parking lots.
When people have strollers,
they don't give a fuck about their dog.
I'm concerned,
concerned with this little baby,
this dog and go fuck itself.
I just think like,
how hard is it to take that leash and
just tie it to the bench that you're
sitting on it.
It's hard for some people just like,
it's hard to not hold the baby over the
grill enclosure.
Very difficult.
So that compels soon is real.
The struggle is real.
Be Like I've,
you know,
I really,
I really don't want to let this dog go.
What am I,
my favorite dogs ever.
I got a call from these people that I
knew they were a dog watchers and uh,
they found a dog in their neighborhood
and they knew that I had dogs and the
new,
I love dogs and this dog had mange.
She had mange all over her body.
She was really sick and they were like,
we don't even know if,
if she's going to be able to make it
like so fucked,
like open scabs because of it.
She was so beat up.
It was so sad and so they had washed her
up and they had fed her and she was a
really sweet dog and I'm like,
look,
I,
I'll take a chance.
We'll see what happens.
Yeah.
Within like a week,
her manager had grown back.
It was crazy.
It's just the food.
She's needed to be cleaned and needed
food within a week.
Almost all of her hair was like,
it wasn't fully grown.
It was all growing back and she turned
out to be the greatest dog of all time,
but I can't go around those dogs.
I'll have a fucking house full of dogs.
I have 100 dogs.
The one I have now,
I did not plan on having him.
I saw him in a shelter and he was just
the cutest thing and,
and I,
I fostered him and two days in like we
are someone like messaged me because I
made like an instagram account forum so
that like maybe we'll get popular and
people,
someone would adopt him and then someone
messaged me and immediately I got the
message and I was thinking like,
don't you take my dog
was mine.
So He's,
he's a Staffordshire bull terrier,
which is basically like a pit bull.
Yeah.
It's like a,
I call it a pit bull face on a pig's
body.
It's like he's adorable.
And he like,
what's crazy is so that breed,
if you were to buy one,
they're $2,500 and that's one without
training,
without anything like.
And he was just sitting in a shelter and
so anytime someone's like,
oh well you know,
I've got to go to a shelter because I
need to really specific or sorry,
I gotta go to a breeder because I needed
a really specific dog.
I'm just like put their out there.
Anything you want.
Every single kind of dog is out there.
And he's my mascot now I take them with
me to comedy clubs and everything.
Really?
Yeah.
Because he doesn't bark at all.
I've heard him bark maybe like 10 times.
Oh that's awesome.
So I just,
he hangs out in the greenroom.
Uh,
he like,
he'll find like whatever comic,
like left,
like a box of like merge,
like sometimes someone will ship merged
or something.
He'll just find like the box of shirts
and just like use it as a bed.
He's great.
He's smart.
He knows they're useless.
Yeah.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
shelters are tough.
It's tough.
It's tough to go there.
It's tough to see that.
It's just the people are so
irresponsible there.
So irresponsible with pads they get and
we can't have this dog dog shit in the
house.
Like you got to teach them to not shit
in the house next to just give them up
and leave him in a cage and out of
sight,
out of mind.
Go on with their life.
What disturbed me is when I found out
how many animals Peta kills everything
year.
Oh,
I got into it with the pita.
A spokesperson on twitter.
Did you?
Oh,
I fucked her up.
Good.
I was pretty happy with those at about.
So she followed me on twitter and I just
write back and I go,
Hey,
I'm,
I'm so honored for the follow sincere
the Peta spokesperson.
I'm,
could you let me know why Peter has a 90
percent kill rate?
And so she starts doing,
you know,
the standard pr thing of like,
well,
you know,
people bring dogs to us that,
don't really have much of a chance
elsewhere.
And so,
you know,
we're kind of a last resort.
And I go,
Oh,
well,
uh,
that's actually not true because I know
of shelters that are like that and their
kill rate is one 10th of yours.
So if you could explain it.
And I just kept hammering her about and
hammered her about it and hammer
lightly,
um,
calmly.
I wasn't like,
shut up bitch like this,
that gets you nowhere,
you know,
I was just trying to outwit her and it
was a,
it was a lot of fun.
And eventually then she's like,
look,
I don't speak for Peta.
And I was like,
well,
in your bio,
on your twitter it says head of
communications.
So,
uh,
you do,
and now you're speaking to me.
Is it a resource issue as PD does not
have the money to take Carolyn?
It's actually a batman issue.
Um,
you know,
how like ratio goal pause.
Yeah.
You know,
how,
how the idea of like in a,
in the first Christian Bale Batman,
a racial goal was kind of like who's
that?
Okay,
so the,
the bad guy in Bama and they were like,
we need to save the city by destroying
it,
right?
Like the humans are destroying
themselves,
so we're going to wipe this out and,
and so that'll prevent the problem and
that's what it is.
Peta is basically like,
there's a problem with like,
we love these dogs and so to stop them
from overbreeding we're just going to
murder a lot of them.
Like that's where they go with it.
We'll see the head of Peta when you get
to the top crazy person,
it's,
well,
it's not murdered for saying this.
No,
you shouldn't be.
If they do,
they're rude animal liberation
organization.
The,
the,
the real,
the at the very head of a lot of these
really radical animal rights movements.
And by the way,
I love animals so I get it.
I get the wanting pets to be taken care
of,
but they don't want pets to be taken
care of.
They don't want pets.
They think animals should be free,
all animals should be free.
All livestock,
all pets,
none of that should be real.
All animals.
She just existed in some sort of a wild
state.
They also,
uh,
she's gone on the record many,
many times talking about how people
should be eradicated.
Yeah.
And you know,
and,
and like things like that and the idea
that they are dangerous.
I've had them,
they just are,
you know,
there are thousands of years of breeding
to fight each other and if you're
irresponsible,
dog owner,
pitbulls can be fucking dangerous.
Yeah.
But at the same time,
they say that about my dog,
about my staffy.
Yeah.
But staffordshires terrorists.
That's ignorance.
They're not the same breed.
See,
there's a genetic according to law.
They are.
Yeah,
but that's not.
It's not right.
The law is incorrect.
It's just some stuff written down on
paper when you deal with the actual
genetic lines of the dog.
I've had dogs that were,
there,
were there.
The line was from fighting dogs and they
were impossible.
He couldn't take them to the dog park,
couldn't take them.
It didn't matter how much I trained
them,
they much how I,
how much I was with them all the time.
When dogs had blow up around them,
he would get aggressive and he want to
fight while night.
I agree with you on a lot of things,
but this is.
This is one where where I have a
completely different line because like I
have a dog who is Chihuahua Basset Hound
and I can't bring her nero that dogs,
but that's an exception to the rule.
Pit Bulls are kind of the rule.
The problem with pitbulls is if you get.
It's a very dangerous dog.
They're super powerful.
They're really aggressive and they
don't.
They don't respond to pain the way a lot
of other dogs do because it's been bred
out of them.
Like if you follow the way they breed
dogs for fighting.
When dogs fight,
if they back away,
if they cower,
they were killed.
That was the whole Michael Vick thing is
that it killed all these dogs that quit
in fights.
So when you have all of that
reinforcement genetically and you're
dealing with a breed that's been raised
like this for hundreds and hundreds of
generations,
you're dealing with an incredibly
aggressive draw a dog with a really high
kill drive.
And when these dogs with high prey drive
or given to irresponsible people,
that's when you're getting all babies
getting killed.
Little kids getting killed,
I mean it is breed specific,
but I mean that's also the same train of
thought that people,
you know,
I,
if you can put on a powdered wig and say
that about quote unquote the Negro.
No you couldn't because they weren't
bred for fighting and killing.
If you bred a bunch of people just for
fighting and killing.
Yeah,
you can make that distinction.
But pit bulls bred for fighting.
I mean that's the.
That's what they were bred for.
That's why they look that way.
I mean,
this is a thing that's been recent
though.
They used to be used in hundreds of
generations.
It's not that recent.
I mean they used to be,
you know,
the PIPA was America sweetheart.
Yeah.
The PD from the little rascals had the
pip,
you know,
whatever it was,
but the was almost America's mascot by
the way.
Before the Eagle.
Yeah.
The eye.
And I think the problem is also is that
if a dog looks like a pitfall because
people actually isn't even a breed.
It's a,
what is it,
American something terrier.
I'm is the actual breed that people are
talking about.
Well,
it was an American bulldog mixed with a
terrier.
Terriers are more aggressive and then
they made the new breed.
Yeah.
And then.
But if you get a blood line from one
that is a fighting dog,
and this is not someone I'd love
pitbulls.
I have friends that have pit bull.
I love them.
They're the sweetest,
most friendly dog,
but if handled correctly,
they still have a problem being
aggressive with other dogs.
A lot of them do.
Yeah.
And they're really powerful dogs and in
the hands of the wrong people,
it's.
We're not talking about labs.
Okay.
We have a lab.
Labs are like universally loving and
nice.
You can get the exception to the rule.
You get a bad lab,
but overall Labrador retrievers are
really friendly,
easy going dogs,
so when someone has a lab you go,
oh,
he's got a lap.
When someone has a pit bull,
there's a fucking reason why people go,
oh great.
He's got a pit bull because a lot of
them are fucking crazy a lot.
Well there and I think it.
I think it boils down to who is handling
the dog and the idea of if you.
I like,
I hate when someone is like,
I'm thinking of getting a pimple.
It's like,
well,
either you need to know everything about
it and then you get one or you don't
what?
You have to have a yard that contained
that dog for sure.
You have to be on top of it.
When it comes to training,
you have to really be aware.
You have to read books on it.
You should probably seek help with the
professional,
the behavioral specialist with dogs,
but even then,
if some dog threatens your dog or
grounds or on your dog,
it's likely that your dog's going to
clamp ahold of it's neck.
That dog's going to get fucked up,
but that's also why I'm a huge proponent
of leash laws.
I think by the way,
if la fuck these parking tickets,
leash laws like you and you enforce
leash laws and we will,
we will have more money than any city in
the world.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
I guess how many people really walk
around with your dog without a leash?
Is that really a problem?
I,
I couldn't.
I don't know if I've ever walked my dog
without running into someone who had an
off leash dog.
Yeah,
that's irresponsible.
Let's turn on a trail or something like
that.
I had,
but even then I had a.
So I was walking my dogs on this trail
on a leash park in,
I think it was fryman and uh,
these two huge dogs come bounding at us,
right?
And now look,
maybe they playful.
One of mine's not,
one of mine is fucking terror when it
comes to other dogs.
And so immediately we pick them up and
this lady starts lecturing us about how
you're not socializing your dog's
correctly and they'll never learn.
And
I was like,
well,
if you want my dog to bite your dog,
I can put her back down if you'd like.
But like that's why learn.
Yeah.
People who,
whose lives are a mess.
Always love correcting people.
Yeah.
I called to get your shit together.
I call it a incorrect,
incorrect.
It's like,
thanks for correcting me.
Yeah.
You need to socialize your dog.
What?
First of all,
it's a little dog that you can pick up
and big dogs running around.
Probably should pick them up.
Yeah.
Dogs like to bite little dogs.
They,
they do it all the time.
Yeah.
It still looks like a raw,
especially if it's the wrong kind of
dog,
you know,
like huskies,
all skeezer,
Akitas,
you know,
like real aggressive dogs.
There are so many people.
There was one in my,
uh,
in my old neighborhood.
We're walking our dogs and all of a
sudden his dog comes charging at us and
it was like a little dog.
And so we pick our,
our dogs and my wife feels lease your
damn dog.
And the guy goes,
this is a public space.
And I go,
yeah,
that's why you lease your dunk.
But where was this?
Just a little lawn of an apartment
complex.
Oh,
you know,
like just a,
just a place where people walk the dogs
all the time.
Do you believe unleashing your dogs on
trails and stuff too?
Like when you're in parks and.
Uh,
I mean if it is a non unleashed place,
then that's fine.
If it's at least place.
The problem is,
is that if someone's dog's leash and
someone's dog isn't leashed that's a bad
way for them to me because one dog feels
trapped and.
Right.
So it's about expectation.
So if I know that they're gonna be non
leashed dogs there,
I'm fine because I know I'm prepared and
I'm ready,
you know,
and the,
and the dog's prepared and et Cetera.
But if like all of a sudden the dog just
comes out of the woods,
like,
that's not,
that's not safe.
Yeah,
that's true.
They're not robots,
you know,
they're not.
Well,
there's so much variety in the way dogs
behave and the way dogs treat other dogs
and other people.
It's just,
it's always like,
what's this dog like,
here comes the dog,
what are we dealing with?
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I have no idea.
And I know that like even when I stopped
for them on the road,
I know that's dangerous to do because
you have no idea if that dog is going to
like try to bite you.
But I've been bit.
I haven't.
Um,
yeah.
I keep a,
I keep a slip lead in the car.
I'm constantly keep an eye just have to
slowly to my trunk.
Wow.
I've seen so many of them and I can't
tell you how many times I'm like,
I wish I had something to run this.
And when you capture them then when you
put them in your car,
what do you do?
You just bring them right to a shelter a
well so far I actually have not had that
happen.
Usually it is either like one time there
was someone else there that happened to
work for rescue that also stopped,
uh,
you know,
one time there was a like a pet store
right nearby.
So I kinda like brought the dog into the
pet store and they were able to hold him
while a while.
You know,
the owner came,
Huh?
So I actually haven't,
but.
Oh No.
You know,
the one time,
yeah,
I brought,
I brought a dog to in Louisville.
I brought a dog to a shelter.
Uh,
the one that,
uh,
this past week where like I put her in
the car and then I had to be super
careful and disinfect everything because
you never know.
Oh,
dad's and I have a dog and so I just
basically I had my buddy who I had my
dog with me when I saw the other dog,
so I had my buddy,
we were like half a mile from the hotel
so he just walked to the hotel with my
dog
and then I just drove the other dog to
the shelter.
And then you just hope someone adopts
it.
You just put it on social media and you
hope.
Yeah.
If you pick up a dog that has fleas,
the fleas getting the carpet of your
car.
Well,
but,
but that's the thing I've given up on
flea prevention really,
like it's something where I give my dogs
a medicine for it,
but like California has such a fucking
flea problem that there's nothing you
could do,
like after a certain amount,
like every,
every dog has fleas.
Really.
It's,
it's some,
some react to it worse than others.
My dogs don't have fleas,
but there is.
Look,
you live in a special place.
You live in a magical cloud above Los
Angeles.
Magical cloud,
the to killing thing.
So they always fucks with me.
It's amazing to me that people will
justify it.
Also there's video of them going to a
porch and like leading someone's dog off
their porch and taking it and killing it
within a couple of hours.
Yeah.
And why do they do that?
Why did they lead it off the porch?
Again?
They want to eradicate it.
They just don't want meds.
They just don't want pets.
Yeah.
So I think it's better to kill the pet
than allow the pet to be with the person
that they love to lead a life of
slavery.
So bizarre to see that kind of radical
thinking,
but that's just the case with
everything,
right?
I mean you have your reasonable people
and then you have your people that take
that to the utmost and take it to the
furthest,
furthest point of rational thinking to
the point where you're like,
you're killing all the dogs.
You capture.
One of my favorite things that I've seen
was A.
John Stewart showed a video of people
merging to the,
I think it was like the Holland tunnel
or the Lincoln tunnel or something,
and it was like one car,
one car,
one like you're supposed to do with
merge.
And every now and then someone would
drive up on the shoulder and go around
all of them and just be like,
fuck everybody but me,
you know.
And that is who creates terrible policy.
That is who shouts from the rooftops
about it.
Like that is who most of us will just
drive one car,
one car.
Yeah.
And understand that that's what you do
because that's what you want to have.
That one guy that's late for work every
day.
It's like,
fuck,
I saw a guy do that the other day.
He,
he hit the breakdown lane near a light
light was about to turn green and he got
into the,
the side lane where people park and just
gunned it through the intersection.
Yeah,
almost plowed into people.
And then you see him speeding up ahead
because he was probably late for work
was early in the morning.
You know,
there's so many people that everyday
they barely make it to work on time and
it's,
it's like this adrenaline rush.
They're addicted to.
They don't even realize it.
They're supposed to leave at seven,
10,
seven,
Fifteen,
20,
fuck,
fuck.
And they run out the door and it's,
that's the race.
That's the,
that's where they're getting their
chart.
They're not getting chased by saber
tooth tigers,
but they are getting their adrenaline
fix because that's the danger.
Another thing that,
uh,
that another Chris Bauer story,
another comic was asking him about
because he drives around and gigs all
the.
And someone asked
him about like,
because he said,
oh yeah,
I never speed.
And he's like,
what do you,
what do you mean you never speed?
How do you get there?
And he's like,
well I'm in my forties now so I wake up
15 minutes earlier
and then I still get there because
that's all it is.
Like at the same time it's hard not to
speed because when you're like,
when you have these straightaways when
there are no cars near you and is like,
why the fuck is the speed limit 60 here?
Are you kidding me?
I can go 100 safely easy.
But at the same time the idea of like,
well I just.
What are you going to say if,
unless you're doing like a 10 hour
drive,
you're not saving anything significant.
Right?
Then there's the idea of the man telling
you how fast you can go.
Fuck him man.
Well I think you should be able to,
to unlock levels like on your driver's
license.
That's a good idea.
Like I could,
I could get a 75 mile an hour speed
limit.
I could easily drive
75,
have no problem.
Right?
If you're like a race car driver,
if you know how to really drive and
you're super responsible with your
choices of lane changing and things
along those lines,
yeah,
you should.
Being able to drive faster.
The problem is how do you enforce it?
You have to pull the person over and
then maybe get a sticker on your car,
something that's good and even drive an
ugly car.
Like I would drive,
like I give me a purple fender,
you know,
GimMe Gimme,
something ridiculous that the cops can
easily see that and go,
okay,
that's a $75 an hour guy
and if you text in your car,
if you text while you're driving,
when you actually move.
I mean,
how many times have I looked over and I
saw this car acting weird and they're
texting,
you should just,
you should lose your license for a week.
Here's the better question is when do we
pay on the show?
All You have to pee.
Go peanut.
All right,
cool.
We're going to wrap this up soon.
Anyway,
I got a Boogie soon.
All right,
I'll be quick.
Go ahead.
Go Pete,
Steve Hofstetter.
Ladies and gentlemen,
if you want to see that video,
you can find it on his youtube channel.
Actually,
if just look up,
Steve Hofstetter destroys a heckler.
You'll find it easy to find,
but he's got a couple of multimillion
view heckler videos.
Wow.
Maybe it's him.
Maybe Bates.
These people,
we don't need to watch them,
but he's probably Bayton these
motherfuckers.
Good dude though.
But crazy traveling around fucking
leashes,
kidnap a dogs and yelling at Peta
people,
young mother.
Um,
when I was walking around Runyon,
uh,
I was just,
I had my headphones on.
Dog came running up behind me.
It's just,
it scared me.
Like whatever.
Just a dog and then I kind of like good
away a dog and away shoe shoe kind of
thing.
I know there's a girl behind me,
but it came back like five minutes later
was jumping at me and barking and I was
like,
get the.
I finally got pissed,
you know what I mean?
It was like she was taking her dog and
picking it up and get mad at me because
I got mad at the dog.
Well,
the people get mad that you don't know
their dogs.
Cool.
Yeah.
Like how do I know your dog could be a
fucking maniac.
Crazy bitch.
I don't even know her.
I'm talking to her earlier.
She's really well,
what do I do if I kick it and I'm an
asshole now because your dog's going to
bite me.
I got to take a bite.
Well that's also the problem with
running with headphones on,
but running with headphones on.
It's so much more inspirational and
running without headphones on.
Just
found out today.
There's a cool thing on spotify.
You can have it set to your,
uh,
your,
your pace,
your
beats per minute and play like a
symphonic Movi hike,
action theme song stuff.
So you pick your running
play,
that kind of stuff.
But
it was talking about are running with
headphones on.
A dog came up to him and barking at them
and know that that is a disturbing
happens.
It can if you're in the wrong place,
the wrong time.
And you know,
obviously people do get bit,
you know,
fucking German shepherds,
man.
Those little fuckers.
My dog got bit by a German girl,
daughter rather got bit by a German
shepherd recently.
These people had this dog and I'm like,
this is not a regular dog.
You can't just have this fucking dog in
your yard.
He teach this dog and they're like,
oh,
well.
She's a little rambunctious and it's
like,
I go,
no,
this is a working dog.
This is a working dog.
Do you understand like this is a really
smart dog.
It's going to figure out a way out of
your yard and when kids are fucking
with,
it's going to bite them.
This is what's going to happen.
Unless you teach it like you have to
take this thing now when it's eight
months old and you got to really train
it because it's already fucking 70
pounds.
It's already a big ass dog.
Like you're gonna have a responsibility.
When you have a dog like this.
This is not.
This is not like a bulldog that'll just
sit there and is happy to just drink
water and chill out.
This is a super active,
really aggressive dog.
Yeah.
It needs to think.
It needs to.
You need to give it puzzles.
Maybe you can get the and get the birth
control pill.
This is a sort of the same thing along
those same lines we were talking about
with pitbulls,
like these animals are bred for a very
specific activity.
In order to discourage that activity,
boy you're gonna have to fucking throw a
lot of tennis balls.
You're going to have to get this dog a
lot of exercise.
You're going to have to give this dog a
lot of,
a lot of activity,
a lot of stuff that they can occupy
their mind with humans being bred for
office jobs.
Yeah,
exactly.
Dude.
You just fucking nailed it.
Steve Hofstetter.
We got to wrap this up.
I gotta get Outta here,
but I knew that I would have held.
I would have held the P for a little
longer to do.
This is a casual show.
But um,
so,
uh,
where can people see you?
Where do they see you live?
Where can they find your twitter is
Steve Hofstetter?
Yeah.
H O f f s
no one.
No one.
No.
Mother F s t e t t e R.
Okay.
Sorry.
That's okay.
It happens all the time.
Um,
my youtube is a,
just youtube,
the Hofstetter,
but you could also just google it.
Um,
and I do.
I have a podcast called Major League
podcast,
which is where I interviewed baseball
players.
Oh,
you're a baseball fan?
Yeah.
Huge baseball phone.
Cool.
Yeah,
I'm doing a thing now where I'm throwing
out first pitches.
It was like a thing.
Oh,
nice.
Like my favorite thing to do.
Well listen man,
you're funny.
Funny Dude.
The heckler video.
It's awesome.
I love that it's blown up for you and
you're getting all this attention and
all this cool shit's happening for you.
You're part of that man and uh,
you know,
you tweeting out life has changed for me
from six weeks ago.
It's crazy.
It's awesome.
I love it.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
And more success to you,
sir.
Thanks for having me on my project.
My pleasure.
All right,
well that's it for the week.
You fucks.
So,
uh,
we'll see you soon.
We'll be back next week and much love to
all.
Thank you.
Bye.